[Music]
now for a spectacular biological head
Rachel Peterson from Washington State
wanted to show kids how lungs work so
she purchased some cow lungs from her
local butcher and attached a leaf blower
lungs just looked weird but then again I
guess they weren't designed to travel
around without the rest of the cow
attached some people might think this
looks a little bit gross to see these
lungs being inflated on the table but to
me as well is just I think it's amazing
to see how this organ really works when
a cow breathes it's taking an oxygen
through its bronchial tubes and it goes
through the bronchial tubes and into the
lungs and into these tiny tiny little
tubes called alveoli and the purpose of
the alveoli is to increase the surface
area where gas exchange can take place
we're talking up to five hundred square
meters of surface area within a lump and
this is to be able to transfer oxygen
into the tissues and to allow co2 or
carbon dioxide to transpire out of the
tissues so surface area is really
critical so ridges leafblower replicates
breathing on a table but these lungs
look like they could burst would they
ever really get this big an ordinary
breath for a cow is about one gallon of
air or five liters but when you take the
lungs outside the body and attach this
leafblower you can inflate them to about
four times that size now that's some
serious lung busting science that you'll
only find in a hack of hers